next guest after a prolific career with
Mississippi State are following guests
fell behind quarterbacks like Paxton
Lynch Christian Hackenberg and Connor
cook in the 2016 draft but he soon
became the starting quarterback for the
Cowboys and apparently he may be due for
a new contract I think I heard something
about that somewhere like every day for
the last couple of months but no matter
how much money he makes I still think of
him as the quarterback who shook his own
hand when he was with us the last time
please welcome one of our favorites dak
Prescott
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh perfect see what's it gonna be like
where everybody knows what you make and
attached is that that contra didn't like
Kirk cousin it's a good problem to have
but here's Kirk who's known as Kirk
Cousins who makes 84 million dollars
guarantee are you ready for that I'm mad
think that's a good problem I don't
think Kirk's arguing anybody with his
name so often just had come up with with
that not the media right with family
with family never my family knows who I
am they know the way that I think close
friends the same way teammates the same
way it's never really brought up just
with the media so unless I'm doing
things like this it's not even a thought
that comes into my head I have people
that I trust that are gonna get it done
see I thought it was gonna get done
prior to the start of the series me too
and I was told that it was gonna get
done like over a weekend before they
started the season how close was it to
getting done I don't know if it was that
close I can't say that I'm not
disappointed that he get that it didn't
get done but I'm definitely confident
that it will there's nothing in me
that'll have any doubt that my team that
the Cowboys we'll work something out
it'll be good for us both yeah it's just
awkward though because you bet on
yourself though right yeah is that what
the like that was the logic when the
season start it's like all right we
can't get it done I'll show you what I
can do
yeah for sure I mean once you started
the season with that once I started the
season without a contract that's what it
was and then after about four or five
games in we contract talks were over
nothing even being discussed and as you
said I bet it on myself and here we are
if you were a first-round draft pick how
do you think that you would be it feels
like there guys like Russell Wilson it
took him a long time before people were
looking at him going like he's a great
quarterback he's going to the Hall of
Fame it's it felt like he had to keep
proving himself and I don't know if
you're not a first-round pick at that
position we still tend to look at
quarterbacks and go yeah but he was a
third-round pick or he was a
fourth-round pick Brady had a chip what
still his shoulder and I think that
Brady being drafted where is is part of
his greatness
something that drives them each and
every day so I went like you said when
you're not drafted in the top of the top
round or the top two rounds there's
always that stigma is that he can't do
it he's not the franchise quarterback
but somebody like me I've been doubting
my whole life so it's it's nothing new
it's something that I actually enjoy
just go out there and prove people wrong
again I have all the confidence in
myself and I know what I'm capable of
when was your welcome to the NFL moment
like I hit or you see somebody on the
field or was there anything where you
gotta go Wow okay this is real
I don't necessarily know if it was in
the game I mean I want to say I was like
the first OTA or so the first of the
second OTA and it was simply just pat
and go and I was throwing it to Jason
Witten and I think I've told this story
before us his patent go has everybody
know it's a minutes that's to look
pretty that's just to look good and I
was throwing it to Jason Witten and I
mean the ball may have been a yard
outstretched and all Jason had to do is
extend his arms a little bit maybe speed
up a tad if he wanted to but he gave me
the alligator arms real short and let
the ball goes over his head and then
throws his arms up and says something
I'm that I won't say on camera and so
I'm just looking at him like that wasn't
that bad of a ball but then once I once
I thought about it and understood what
he was doing he was just showing me what
it takes to be in the league the
accuracy the precision and just just the
details and we laugh about it to this
day but that was the moment I'm like
cheese day I get what you're doing but
our Jason was telling me from day one
yeah I have that welcome to the NFL hit
I can't say I have
well that's good yeah I mean I ran the
ball a bunch in college and played
Alabama and they gave me a few good hits
so yeah I haven't had that in the NFL
thankfully did Nick Saban to recruit you
no he didn't oh I'm sorry that you
didn't care no I didn't care also
sometimes use that as motivation I mean
sure it's motivation but I mean I
wouldn't win played there anyways I
don't think
the fans I'm fine okay if not
Mississippi State then yeah I mean if it
wasn't Mississippi State Oh probably
would have been LSU just because the
whole process kid from Louisiana got
recruited by LSU but I was already
committed to Mississippi State at the
time stuck with my word with Coach
Marlin I went to Mississippi State but
if it wasn't for that I probably would
end up at LSU how often did you talk to
Tim Tebow I know you were 15 as a
tribute to to Tim Tebow yeah like do you
see him have you talked to him when's
the last time you spoke to Tim Tebow
yeah the last time I spoke to Tim maybe
a couple of seasons ago talking about
this charity golf tournament but Tim
somebody that I got to meet because of
coach Mullen just through the process
and got to meet him as I was in college
and shared some words can't say that it
was ever just a mentorship or anything
like that but he's a friend
we're talking to dak Prescott and you
might have heard this he might be in
line for contract or something like that
we'll move on from that
mahomes is getting Holmes is now the one
that you're talking about yeah 200
million dollars deservingly okay sure
what are you driving these days by the
way I mean my bicycle a that I still got
a before I got drafted wait you're still
driving this II haven't been paid what
else am I
what are you gonna buy what do you not
have that you want to buy
yeah there's I don't there's there's not
anything obviously I mean I'm fortunate
I'm blessed
I've made some money I've made some good
money I thankful thankful obviously I
just Sleep Number and to some of my
great sponsors so I mean there's not
anything that I want the money to buy
it'll just be a blessing you'll be
something they'll change generations of
my family there's got to be a car that
you go that's my dream car I mean I've
got an Aston Martin okay there you go
there you go didn't is Tom Brady is he
an Aston Martin I think he is what makes
him like you look at these guys in
quarterbacks
you know like musicians or sports cat
we're always looking to steal something
right
you know shooters in basketball like
what do you what do you pick from guys
what would you take from Brady if you
could yeah I mean obviously just the
consistency how long he's done it I mean
a guy like that you can obviously tell
he prepares he prepares the right way
and he prepares for anything and he's
been doing it for such a long time with
such a high level for me to just be the
preparation and how to stay healthy what
what can I do to make sure my body is
its best and that's why I'm here on
behalf of Sleep Number talking about
that that's my advantage is I'm I
started working with Sleep Number a
couple of years ago and the moment I did
moment I got the bed I noticed a
difference for me it's about I track I
track my weightlifting I track my eating
so why not tracking my sleep if I know
that it's gonna make me a better player
look at that
we started on Tom Brady and then went to
sleep number which is a sponsor of ours
so I mean I know my Sleep Number setting
is 75 I'm 40 yeah well I'm a little bit
better than you
when's the last time you went to the
line of scrimmage and you go this is
gonna be a touchdown I do it often I did
in the Redskins game the touchdown to
Michael gallant beggins only went up
high and caught it that happens a lot I
mean and that comes from the preparation
talking about Tom Brady and how much you
prepare when you studied film and you
know what the defense is doing and you
study plays and you've game planned and
when a coach calls in that play you get
to the line and that play was meant for
that defense yeah your mouth starts
watering and you know it's about that
what's your favorite audible like you
have a good call there's Omaha Omaha
right pretty good yeah I mean I've got a
couple of them I'm not wouldn't wanna
say I'm because obviously when you hear
it you know that's his favorite and
that's that play again so I won't give
him that away would you have a dummy one
that you could want any of you telling
us that it's a dummy one then the
defense will know no I still don't want
to give that away okay how about you
just gave one for us next year I can't
what you want me to say how many I mean
McLovin can you just walk up and go yeah
McLovin McLovin yeah McLovin 252 I mean
that's not a big deal right that's easy
I'm always looking for terms and words
to add some love yeah just just walk up
there and just point out Mike linebacker
and then yell out McLovin McLovin
McLovin
yeah Aaron Rodgers is pretty good at the
line of scrimmage yes yes have you been
able to kind of mimic what he and like
do sample how guys call a play at the
line of scrimmage yeah I definitely mean
when you're watching games you're
checking out guy's demeanor the way the
guys like you said the way they attack
the line of scrimmage call their plays
get the team in the right situation for
me I mean obviously I go back and I
think about Peyton Manning
but Aaron Rodgers has nothing nothing
short of being great of getting his team
in the right the right play dummy
signals dummy plays that aren't meaning
anything and get into the play that he
wants and it's impressive you said the
right thing when you were asked if you
were going to get in touch with Aaron
Rodgers to talk about Mike McCarthy now
that he's your head coach you did you
gave the smart answer and that is no I I
want to I want to experience this on my
own I don't want it I want to have a
clean slate base that's what you're
saying why did you say then yeah I just
don't want anybody else's
opinion to miss shape how I see someone
yeah I mean I think every relationship
is individual and for me that's what
it's about that's how I go into it with
my teammates that's how I go to it with
coaches I want to get them get to know
them for myself and that was fair for
what anybody else has told me how they
are or their ways I'll figure that out
myself and we'll create all in
relationship the whole the the the hip
thing that NBC Concha doing
no long have you been doing that hip
thing two years or so that has been
doing it way longer than me you started
a little hip thing I mean it comes from
Tom house and the guys I trained with so
I mean Brady Brees Matt Ryan I'm sure I
could keep going down the list of guys
that that I know that worked with that
group and and they do the hip thrust as
well but for some reason it gets coined
the dag dance fight well we've had Tom
house on the show before and he talks
about that creating that torque yes and
a lot of guys throw with their arms and
you've really got to be using your hips
your body which is what Brady does we
tried it but I think we pulled a groin
we pulled all our groins like both sides
[Laughter]
and recapping the embarrassing moment we
had outside of our New York studio was a
couple years ago where we went outside
to throw football and dak was out there
and and I was ready to wrap the segment
go back up on the air and dak put his
hand out like this I didn't see him
I had already turned and then you grab
your own hand and shake your and I said
hey that guy could be my quarterback
right there I've never seen Peyton
Manning adjust like that yeah I mean on
the fly low you left me angry
let you hang it I didn't give you any
DAP there get in your plug again for
Sleep Number we know it quite well one
of they've been around with us at about
10 years so we are well versed in how
great Sleep Number is yeah sleep numbers
great I mean obviously I'm thankful
Sleep Number allowing me to be here in
Miami
I speak on their behalf but it's been a
competitive edge for me and now I'm
sharing it with everybody else but sleep
is everything sleep is like a computer
right your body is like in computer if
it tells you to rest
do that don't fight it listen to it and
if you're smart you do it in the Sleep
Number bed that's what I do it on off
the field I've got an advantage and I
believe it's because the Sleep Number
and your Sleep Number setting is 40 40
yeah
I've been playing with it lately in the
off seasons it's just just trying to
figure something out yeah now they 360
smart beds they're awesome thank you for
joining us do you want to light up
McLovin can you light him up a little
bit I'll save it I'll save it
oh you can't throw now right now oh the
shoulder yeah now right now how's the
shoulder it's good it's good it's
improving every day I mean no surgery
no no no we're good I mean I could but
I'd rather not you know I'd rather save
that wrap how about we do how about you
show us the deck dance in the commercial
break
about we teach me loving the make love
in the deck dance we'll take a break
we'll come back and - etana buy a low
and Derek Henry will join you have you
been around Derek Henry I have a
training today kinder coming out in the
convoy incredible person incredible
athlete I could imagine tackling him
though duck yeah me too I'm glad I'm
honest oh my god
all right we'll take a break now - and
Eric will join us in the final hour
always great to see dak Prescott we're
back after this in the Dan Patrick show
for morgue and Patrick's show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]